[Applause]
prince harry and melissa mccarthy are
helping meghan markle celebrate her 40th
birthday
in a special way i think the bigger idea
is yacht party yacht party who's ready
for a yacht
like when you say no yacht do you mean
zero yachts
and no it's not on a yacht i think it's
gonna be a really nice surprise for
people
wednesday marks the milestone birthday
for the duchess of sussex
who enlisted melissa's help for a cute
video to promote a new initiative
hey melissa do you have a second hey yes
of course
i'm working on that remember i told you
i was gonna do that organic garden
that's what i'm doing you know your
camera's on right i can see you
hang on over here i'll i'll be right
back no no it's no problem it's fine
this will probably seem better for you
the clip titled 40x40 which marks
megan's first appearance since giving
birth to her and harry's second child
lillabet diana in june was posted on the
couple's archwell foundation website
and if you look closely you'll see megan
sporting two zodiac
necklaces from jewelry designer logan
hollowell
to rep her kids astrological signs
that's a gemini constellation for archie
and a taurus constellation for lillabet
spicing on the cake yeah
but back to that video it features megan
and melissa having a chat about how to
bring in the duchess's big day
are we finally getting matching tattoos
i mean well you know i already have
something really similar across my back
this one's you and that one's me because
sometimes i'm like
are we twinsies you know maybe we save
it for when i turn 50.
yeah the 50 year old comedian had a few
ideas of her own
are you finally gonna do a suits reunion
okay i i love suits but
why would i do a suits reunion for my
birthday
why would the cast of friends do a
reunion for my birthday
but they did it they did say they would
only ever do it for a historical event
so i guess that means we'll have to keep
waiting on a suits reunion
the company says they have protocols in
place to prevent discrimination but we
also know that they have a ceo who takes
advantage of women
if you're talking about jasmine i'm
talking about women but megan had an
even better
idea i'm asking 40 friends to donate 40
minutes of their
time to help mentor a woman who's
mobilizing back into the workforce
over 2 million women in the u.s alone
and tens of millions around the world
have lost their jobs due to covid
and i think if we all do it and all
commit 40 minutes to some sort of active
service
we can create a ripple effect and
melissa she said she was in
times 40. is it okay if i still
do it in the hat i wouldn't expect
anything less
thanks friend but melissa wasn't the
only one helping megan celebrate her big
day
prince william and kate middleton posted
a snap of the birthday girl on their
official insta story
writing quote wishing a happy 40th
birthday to the duchess of sussex
the royal family account which
represents queen elizabeth ii
shared three pics of meghan along with a
birthday wish
as for the clarence house account which
reps prince charles and camilla
they shared a glam photo of the prince
of wales daughter-in-law along with a
b-day shout-out
but you know what i'll send you off with
this megan's husband
prince harry making an appearance in the
blooper reel for the 40th birthday video
what about an afternoon tea with your
chickens no see i don't really think
that tea with the chickens